thank you very much for joining us
israeli police have caught four of the
six palestinians who escaped from a
maximum security prison on monday to
remain at large the men had escaped by
tunneling their way out of gilboa prison
in northern israel the jailbreak
prompted a large-scale manhunt by the
israeli army and law enforcement
agencies one of the four prisoners who
has been recaptured is zakaria zubaidi
he was a high-profile figure in fatah's
wing the al-aqsa martinez brigade harry
foster has more from west jerusalem
the latest two to be recaptured are
zubaidi and one of the other five
palestinian islamic jihad members who
comprise the rest of the six who escaped
on monday that's muhammad al-arday and
they were picked up
close to the town of nazareth in
northern israel to the east of nazareth
we understand in a
lorry park
there was an attempt it's been reported
on behalf of zebedee to resist arrest he
was uh found to have been trying to get
under one of the uh trucks parked in
that area uh but was arrested along with
the other man he was with neither of
them said to have been armed it seemed
they were by themselves
still obviously inside israeli territory
very similar to what took place in
southern nazareth a few hours earlier on
friday evening when two other men
mahmoud
the supposed ringleader of the escape
the mastermind of the escape and yakub
kharadi
both from again palestinian islamic
jihad they were arrested they were
reportedly spotted looking or
potentially asking for food so all of
this seems to militate against the idea
that this was a highly coordinated
escape with help from the outside
there'd been speculation about the
potential for these men to be on some
kind of operation to try to carry out
an attack or attacks inside israel
perhaps getting into the west bank
perhaps fleeing for jordan none of that
appears to have been the case it seems
they're very much on their own and now
four of the six have been picked up